hi thanks for coming my name is Jess
LeBeau I'm the lead narrative designer
for sniper ghost Warrior 3 I was the
original world designer for the Guild
Wars series I did some original story
work for League of Legends
more recently did DLC for Far Cry 4
I've been with the CI games on this
project for about a year this is Alec
he's also part of our narrative design
team we're gonna walk you through the
demo here so you are an American special
forces operative illegally behind enemy
lines the United States and NATO is
fighting a proxy war it's Russia through
the civil war that's taking place it
means it's an it's an open world
experience okay there are there is a
storyline that does take place in a
particularly linear fashion however
there is a lot of other open world
activities and preparation that you have
to do in order to be able to complete
those elusive so we're now about I'd say
about a third of the way through the
game where we've done we've been doing
collecting Intel doing reconnaissance
we're on our way back to our safe house
to get our next mission but as we're
fond of saying the world itself the
terrain is an enemy in Sniper goes for
three so we want to make sure that we
don't stumble in anything that's going
to kill us so we're going to use one of
our gadgets just demonstrating the drone
when you're in the drone you're in
first-person you'll see that the
mini-map doesn't have any enemies on it
until you tag them the way you tagged
them is to see them either through your
drone through the scope you know hacked
security cameras visualization some
scenes got them all added them to 3d map
and clearly the Russians are up just no
good because they've mined this area
they don't want any incursions again the
terrain can kill you it's an enemy so to
deal with that we've given you a couple
of tools the first is what we call
extreme navigation
repelling parkour climbing over fences
dealing with terrain that you might you
know more vertical things that you might
not necessarily be able to go over the
second is what we call scout mode this
is you accessing your Special Forces
training right things that you already
know as an operative you see here he's
analyzing these footprints out what did
you find careful steps military boots so
probably there was a guy who's sitting
on the minefield
so now Alec has several options he can
extreme navigate his way around it he
can disarm these mines or he can track
this guy who clearly has been the one
that laid mines safely through the
minefield doesn't disappear if you do
not track it the problems or the
difficulties won't appear there the
mines you will be able to go back so
he's also got a skirt this patrol that
he saw earlier and the sniper what you
saw there was our detection meter
stealth is obviously very important to
the game so this is our safe house this
is the crafting bench you can craft
bullets you can craft scopes instance of
your rifle
Alec has picked up some health kits and
some body armor and now he's going to
contact JSOC and get his mission now for
the past few days we've been doing
reconnaissance we know about the Russian
operation here the leader of the
Russians is named general vid kovitch
JSOC says locate him and kill what
you're looking at here again open world
experience this is a local map right
this is just the area so this is a small
section of it this is your safe house
this is another safe house that you've
unlocked either through missions or
exploration when you unlock them you can
fast travel to from one to another and
this isn't teleportation time does pass
but the concede is in an open world we
know that you can safely move from one
state off-limits
so here we are another safe house Alex
going to select some weapons for the
mission with a name like sniper of
course you've got a bunch of
rifles right but we've also got handguns
machine guns knives your drone of course
might need to be repaired if it gets if
you crash into something or it gets shot
you might upgrade it you might have to
buy a new one you might have to retrofit
it for certain tasks so Alex going to
select the knife and sniper rifle if
you've done crafting that'll appear here
when you assemble your rifle and he's
going to head out for the mission as I
mentioned time has passed we have a
dynamic weather system so now it's
raining if we come out here at a
different time it might be foggy it
might also be raining it might be sunny
so things change so what did you find
here and as a weird try because here is
that some of the drugs at the body paper
so we can use the scout mode to learn
information about side quests things
we're calling war crimes right these are
optional but they they can unlock tools
for you later so perhaps this guy was
dragged through here maybe it's a dead
body perhaps it was someone that was
captured maybe if you track them down
you find that someone's been captive and
you you can release them and maybe
they'll give you a key to a tower or
something that will unlock a sniping
position you could use later one of the
other [ __ ] aspects of scout mode is
that you it can access what we call
stances so you hold your rifle
unsupported like this it's more
difficult to control writing you use
parts of your body to control it of you
all sorts of different stances so we
know as a Special Forces operative that
using our rifle up against this piece of
terrain will give us lots of control
Alec can use that then to search for the
general potentially take shots if he
wants to is in tags all of the patrols
and this the enemy
doesn't look like the general is here so
we're going to have to go deeper into
their facility what you see here is a
server location that we tagged earlier
and other reconnaissance so what we're
going to try and do is sneak into the
center of their camp their base and
we're going to hack into their servers
use their own security cameras to see if
we can't locate the gym the game is
never going to tell you where your enemy
is you have to do a little
reconnaissance here this is about you
being a a lone guy behind enemy lines
survival so you can't kill somebody if
you don't know where they are
so you see Alex being very careful as he
moves through here because again the
terrain is an enemy he's watching for
enemy patrols through here the most
direct route to that server is probably
down this road but it looks like except
three looks like three snipers are
covering this area so Alec is going to
use scout mode to find a stream
navigation way to get around it's going
to go up maybe around maybe he's going
to take out one of these snipers as you
see there are vehicles in the game will
be some jets that fly over that can
detect you there are helicopters that
are searching if you get caught it will
set off an alarm they'll shoot you if
the alarm goes off it's not necessarily
mission fail however it's going to make
it a lot harder right so what we do is
we give you challenges and we give you
tools to deal with those challenges and
it's up to you to decide how you want to
tag things kill certain targets execute
your mission if he sets off the alarm
that's not going to be good for us it's
going to be probably demo because we're
in the middle of a camp we're using the
same build here as is on the hands-on
out here there are no cheat codes nor
developer codes would you find it's a
single trail it's a sniper currently so
if he's alone that Hall his position is
really dropped so usually these guys
work sometimes they work in pairs a
spotter and sniper the spotter will also
do what they call sniper security make
sure that no one sneaks up on a pair of
them while they're doing their work but
since this guy's working alone our
training has told us that it's probably
booby-trapped the area Alec will have to
disarm this mine now you see he's tagged
the guy here so he has some several
choices seeking me to take him out with
his rifle or with his suppressed pistol
but both of those do make some noise and
so it's always going to be safer if he
can find a way to do it a little more
quietly
see promise guy huh right
so now alec has taken out one of these
snipers and has opened up a corridor for
him to potentially move through now
realism is very important to us so
you're never going to see a guard come
out put his rifle against the wall light
a cigarette I hope nobody shoots me in
the back of the head they're all going
to have duties they're all gonna have
orders they're all going to be they're
going to have a purpose so in this case
there were sets of snipers that were
covering every angle going into this
particular camp and alec has now opened
up one corridor there are factions in
the game different groups of people some
of them have some of them are enemies
some of them are neutral you can
interact with them in this case what
you're looking at here are Georgians
they're workers they don't have any
weapons but that doesn't mean that if a
foreign special operative pops out of
the bushes with a rifle they're not
going to sound the alarm
the Russians have moved into this this
mining towns the sole mining community
they've taken over the mine they force
the Georgians into working for them and
they're building a uranium enrichment
processing plants in the old mine
they're doing it over the border in
Georgia to avoid international detection
this is part of why you're being ordered
to assassinate this this general because
you want to slow down their progress you
see how it can get extreme navigate over
those rails
it's quite close now so it's got to be
very careful there are no levels in the
game there are no skill points that you
spend you don't level 3 level 10 you
don't click I'm going to get better at
sniping instead you train similar to
what you would do here in the Special
Forces the more you use certain caliber
rifles the more you use your knife the
more you disarm things the better you
get those activities we think this adds
to the realism so Alec has now made it
to the center of the camp here it's
overlooking the server location that we
discovered earlier so he's going to go
through here and tag all the centuries
making sure that they're added to the
mini master doesn't it snuck up on and
then he's going to use this drone to try
and sneak in there and hack the server's
drone like the player can set off an
alarm it can get shot
and it's got it obviously flies so it's
got some advantages but this guy up on
the roof makes it difficult it'll get
spotted so Alec is going to have to take
it out take him out so let me explain to
you our sniping system this is your
rangefinder it's about 100 meters away
little over 100 meters this is the air
temperature this will affect the flight
of your bullet this is the wind
obviously affect aside this is the
humidity it will also affect
and this is the magnification this will
change based on what you've crafted for
your scope so tell us about the scope
okay so as you can see right now it's a
little bit oversensitive I need to
stabilize it so what I can do is to
enter a stance called multi neck so I'm
stabilizing my rifle on my arm and which
gives me much more accuracy as just said
these guys around a hundred meters so
I'm going to kind of break my scope to
100 meter and as you can see there's a
little bit of a tiff here Tom this is
how far your bullet is going to drift
based on the conditions so Alec is going
to breathe out one shot one kill
so now he's got a corridor that he can
use for his drone but of course he
doesn't wanted to stand there like a
dummy on the on the edge of the cliff
with his control so he's going to back
up the cover so that he doesn't get
spotted by a patrol or a passive
helicopter it's a hard part's fighting
force enough so the drone flies similar
to the to a regular drone right it can
it can drift around you can hit things
and damage it it's quite fun but a
little bit difficult he's got to avoid
the patrol route for the helicopter you
can see there's Intel that the drone can
pick up for you he's going to try and go
over the top and in through the window
so that he's got a straight shot down
from the balcony just go
see it's discovered a sniping spot that
you potentially use for for for further
missions this is you basically knowing
what vantage points would be good to use
again you don't have to use the sniping
locations it's up to you how you execute
the mission huh
Alec hasn't had his vodka today so his
driving is a little impaired so now he's
into the center here he's got a pretty
good vantage point it's pretty close now
but he still has to watch out for these
patrols mm-hmm I need to aim into this
little smaller bunker this is what I
call my look Skywalker moment
oh wow oh come on
anyway so here we are we've got servers
this one we packed into is access three
different camera networks you can see
there are five cameras here at seven
here so we're going to hack this take
control of it and now Alec can control
the cameras you can see you can use your
Scout mode through the cameras that's
that was the hotel interest there's a
couple of turrets here the helipad guy
there there's that control again so
looks like the general is not here not
at this site anyways we'll have to try
another set of cameras here
okay here's our general this is one of
the cooler storytelling tools that we've
got right we have our own mocap studio
so whenever you're near any NPC
interaction through a security camera
through your drone or nearby you can
overhear their conversations and this
will advance the story the main story
the sub quests the overall world story
and everything every single interaction
to his voice you can hear all of that
this is the general and his wife I'm
gonna zoom in a little bit of a
voyeuristic moment I always feel like
we're intruding on them I should say
this is the the general and his
soon-to-be widow relative she is the
head of the uranium enrichment facility
which is built inside the mine you'll be
able to go down there and read missions
in there later on now that we've tagged
him we know where he's at we can move on
to the second part of our mission which
is killing so you see here that we've
got his name we've got Intel we've
collected on him and these other
locations these other things you're
seeing are our sniping locations we've
unlocked these at different points the
white numbers are the distance from that
sniping location to our current position
the yellow ones are the are the distance
from saiping location to the target so
Alec which one do you want to you okay
so I think I'm going to take the first
one it's just what the closest to my
location right now and it's the longest
shot so yeah I'm gonna show off your
sniping skills I'm gonna say that even
after the drone I know right
yeah I'm not sure anymore can you look a
little quick back so you see this one
location there's only three meters away
from our dinner you if you wanted to
kill him with a knife that might be a
good location to go to however we know
that there's a battalion of Russians
here right so probably not the kind of
location that you can exfiltrate for
however if you spent a day or so or
several hours watching his his movements
perhaps is a certain time of day he
meets with his commanders you might be
able to hide another location and take
him out with your knife the advantage
that this position has though it's going
to be the hardest shot because it's the
farthest away it's also going to be the
farthest away from his guard
it'll be easier to accidentally when you
if you read about any of these like
elite sniper programs right these like
special ops sniper programs obviously
shooting is an important aspect but the
other maybe even more important aspect
is stealth that means you have to learn
how to infiltrate and exfiltrate no one
is coming to get you in this game right
you are on your own you're going to have
to plan your entry route and your exit
strategy you need to know what's behind
you so Alec has left the facility and it
has to enter the perimeter again because
his vantage point was kind of on the
outside of the perimeter space and
sneaking back in and he's going to move
his way to the sniping location here
while he does are there any questions
anything we've talked about so far using
what you can you can calculate how every
blankets that we're trying to to make it
as accurate as possible so if you are a
trained sniper well we we do have a we
have next sniper on on our staff who you
know it is advising us on all these
things and you can either
it's all team again its challenges and
and tools right so these are things from
your training that you think these are
me good vantage points and there are
advantages to it because you know when
you're selecting them how far they are
from your target but it's really up to
you yeah I mean you know your longer
shot and all that stuff we're gonna do a
team that's for you I mean of course you
want to know how hard and what the most
wind you know what the worst conditions
were that you shotty and all that oh you
worked in many ways I can talk about
from the night about well you know the
more you use it the better you'll get at
it but it's really about your play style
right we want you to be able to play the
game however you want this is not a
running gun shoot like this is really
tactical and so we're we're not going to
tell you the best way to do it right
we're not going to tell you you have to
do it the way we want you to do it
instead we're doing we're setting up
scenarios if we think would be realistic
and then we say okay here are your tools
go get and obviously we want to make it
fun so there are going to be some things
in reality that we're maybe not in the
game because that'd be too hardcore but
realism is is very important
getting close to our location here wait
where you learning here so this is a set
of the tracks so probably there is a
sniper on this fire
so no lines he does two enemies so he's
going to have to take out one very
quietly so that the other doesn't hear
it otherwise he'll raise the alarm at
this point if the alarm is raised were
super deep in inside the Russian camp at
odds of us getting out after to killing
the target really low you see he dropped
a machine gun
you have to prep for these missions
right you can't carry you know every
weapon you pick up right so you pick
them up for four for crafting such
okay so now this now our spot is clear
we can get into position see there
another stance that's suggested based on
our training this would be it but you
don't have to use that stance in fact
you'll see that alex is going to take a
different stance so here's our guy we
spent the last few days learning about
him and his movements we intercept we
hacked into their their computers we got
his orders we realized that he's unhappy
about the speed that the processing
plant the richmond facility is moving
forward they're behind schedule and he's
told them they have three days to get
back on schedule or he's going to deal
with it himself we also know where he's
going to be after today next couple of
days so if we wanted to try and take him
out at a different location we can do
that if perhaps we're happier we like
the the city better than having to take
him out in the middle of a military camp
but you can see the the soldiers that
have been here been pushing the foremen
have been pushing the the workers very
hard because of trying to get up on
schedule
and they know the general has arrived
but they still didn't make it they're
not on time and the general is here and
he's going to take matters into his own
hands
despite the fact that we have a labor
dispute
there's only one way to deal with
something in Russian military apparently
so he's not a very nice guy so we're
going to go ahead another shot and your
kill now the alarm has been sounded and
Alex needs alkanes to exfiltrate skin
problema get the machine gun
so for the demo we said just just for
time we're going to go ahead set a black
hockey in an excellent rating pick them
off also choppers are just cool but in
the actual game this will never happen
people not be will not be picked up by a
helicopter that's just suddenly drops it
you're now going to be responsible for
your own exit strategy and that's the
demo